si elle remporte la primaire populaire
christiane taubira se lancera dans la
course à l'elysée sa carrière politique
la candidat qui a débuté en guyane une
femme candidate aux législatives un
billard aujourd'hui christiane taubira
delannon changer tiken mais a juré
semble-t-il d'un large soutien se lance
dans la bataille
1992 christiane taubira de la non du nom
de son ex mari selon dans sa première
bataille politique était gagné à 41 ans
l'ancienne militante indépendantiste
diplômé en économie est élu député en
mars 1993 mesdames messieurs les
ministres collègues parlementaires
rapidement christiane taubira se fait
une place dans le paysage politique en
1993 jean-pierre elkabbach parle d'elle
comme d'un phénomène vous êtes une sorte
de phénomène parce que je crois que
quand on vous a vu vous a entendu on
vous oublie pas r vous oubliera pas en
1999 elle défend une proposition de loi
historique celle affirmant que
l'esclavagé est un crime contre
l'humanité j'ai essayé avec dignité avec
force avec loyauté surtout de porter une
demande une aspiration collective une
aspiration collective qui aboutit à une
loi en 2001 et qui porte son nom un nom
plus tard en 2002 c'est sa première
tentative à l'élection présidentielle
investi par le parti radical de gauche
elle est la première femme noire
candidate à l'elysée
christiane taubira version 2002 c'est
une grosse voiture un discours
universaliste social et anti
sécuritaires c'est la france continue à
s'enfermer dans la peur le lien social
va continuer à se dissoudre mais elle ne
rassemble que 2,3 pour cent des voix au
premier tour la prochaine grande étape
de sa carrière politique c'est en 2012
avec l'élection de françois hollande
à 60 ans elle devient pour la première
fois ministre et quel ministre numéro
quatre du gouvernement ministre de la
justice c'est elle qui portera une des
propositions phare de françois hollande
le mariage pour tous
une loi qui divise la société et qui va
faire de christiane taubira la cible
d'attaqués racistes sa photo associé au
mot singe est la une du journal
d'extrême droite minute ce sont des
propos d'une extrême violence parce que
ces propos prétendent m'expulser de la
famille humaine nous allons livrer
bataille parce que nous avons des
batailles sémantique à livrer nous avons
des batailles culturel à livrer nous
avons des coquettes politique à refaire
et nous sommes bien déterminés à le
faire en 2016 elle quitte le ministère
sur un désaccord politique avec françois
hollande concernant la déchéance de
nationalité
depuis christiane taubira est restée
discrète avant de revenir sur le devant
de la scène pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
[Musique]